[موسيقى]
نواصل مع حضراتكم هذه التغطيه بالطبع
تداعيات الاقتصاديه لهذا الحرب او لهذه
الحرب كانت خطيره للغايه لذلك فان جانبا
من التغطيه الخاصه بالعربيه يركز بالتاكيد
على تداعيات الاقتصاديه لهذه الحرب انتقل
الى زميلي ناصر اليك ناصر شكرا
[موسيقى]
قبل اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا مشاهدينا
كانت اغلب التوقعات تشير الى ارتداد قويا
للاقتصاد الاوروبي عقب الجائحه لكن
البلدان الاوروبيه دفعت ثمنا غاليا بسبب
الحرب نتابع التفاصيل اكثر في هذا التقرير
الصراع العسكري غير المعادله الاقتصاديه
في اوروبا حيث يتوقع البنك الدولي الا
يسجل الاقتصاد الاوروبي اي نمو هذه السنه
مقرره بتقديره سابقه كانت تتوقع نموا
بواحد فاصل تسعه
فهي الدوله الصناعيه الوحيده المرشحه
للانكماش هذه السنه الحرب ادت الى تباطؤ
النشاط الاقتصادي بسبب تعطيل سلاسل
التوريد وتراجع الثقه كما ان اسعار الغذاء
وصلت الى اعلى مستوى لها على الاطلاق في
مارس من عام 2022 بعد بدء العمليات
العسكريه ولكن الضرر الاكبر كان الارتفاع
الحاد في اسعار الطاقه الذي ادى الى تضاعف
اسعار المستهلكين اربع مرات مقرره بعام
ويقدر بعض الخبراء ان الحرب شطبت نقطتين
مئويتين من نمو الاقتصاد الاوروبي
يمكننا ان نقيس اثر الحرب بشكل مباشر على
فواتير الطاقه عند ذروه في بريطانيا مثلا
تكلفه الطاقه ارتفعت 4% في فرنسا كان
الرقم اقل نسبيا بسبب الطاقه النوويه ولكن
في المانيا كان الرقم اعلى من بريطانيا
وبالتالي نحو نصف الارتفاع في التضخم كان
ناتجا بشكل مباشر عن الحرب
صدمه الحرب دفعت العديد من البلدان
الاوروبيه لتقليل اعتماده على روسيا
لتحصيل الطاقه المانيا التي كانت تعتمد
على روسيا لتحصيل النصف امداداتها من
الغاز وثلث الامدادات النفطيه قامت بتنويع
مصادر الطاقه لدرجه انها لا تعتمد اليوم
على روسيا بحسب وزير الماليه ايطاليا
بدورها قلصت والدتها من الغاز الروسي من
40 الى 25% كما يعمل الاتحاد الاوروبي على
الاستغناء عن الغاز الروسي تماما بحلول
عام 2027
مع الاسف الحرب في اوكرانيا مستمره ولكن
اثروا الحرب على اوروبا تراجع لان الناس
بدات تتعايش مع غياب الغاز الروسي وحتى
اذا كان هناك ضعف في النمو هذه السنه فنحن
لا نتوقع انكماشا اقتصاديا شديدا وهذا
افضل من توقعاتنا السابقه
وجدير بالذكر انه على رغم من كل تلك
الجهود لتقليل الاعتماد على روسيا الى ان
ازمه الطاقه ادت الى افلاس العديد من
الشركات والمنشات الصناعيه
ضربه قاسيه طلاقاتها اقتصادات الدول
الاوروبيه وبريطانيا بسبب الحرب
الاوكرانيه خلال السنه الماضيه ومع
استمرار الصراع العسكري تعمل تلك البلدان
على تعايش مع الواقع الجديد امله ان تعود
الى مسار التعافي لاحقا هذه السنه كارينا
كامل العربيه لندن
مساء الخير اخ ناصر وجميع مشاهدي العربيه
انا بيودي ان ابدا بان
مديره صندوق النقد الدولي في مؤتمر داووس
الاخير في الشهر الماضي قالت بان الاسوء
لم ياتي بعد بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي
طبعا هذه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه التي
دخلت عامها الثاني كما ذكرت دفعت بمنظمه
التجاره العالميه الى ان تخفض توقعاتها
اللي هو التجاره الدوليه في العالم
خلال هذا العام بمقدار النصف تقريبا وهذا
لم يحصل في الماضي مطلقا بالنسبه لمنظمه
التجاره العالميه
فتوقعت ان ينخفض من اربعه وسبعه في عشره
في المئه الى اثنين ونصف في المئه ويرتبط
هذا التخفيض بمشاكل ثلاثه سلاسل التوريد
الذي بدات في جائحه كوفيد ولكنها للاسف
الشديد استمرت
لتزايد اسعار الطاقه والمواد الغذائيه كما
ذكرتم في التقرير حيث تشكل اوكرانيا
وروسيا عالميا ما يزيد عن 30% من صادرات
القمح والحبوب
دكتور فواز نعرف بانه كان هناك صدمه في
الطلب عقب الجائحه مع التعافي السريع
خروجا من الجائحه وجاءتنا صدمه العرض بسبب
الحرب الاوكرانيه بالكثير من المواد
الحبوب الاسمده وغيرها ولكن هل تعتقد بانه
ما نشهده الان العالم يدخل في مخاض لاعاده
رسم سلاسل الامداد متاثرا بالعوامل
العسكريه العوامل الجيو السياسيه والعوامل
الاقتصاديه البحته وبالتالي هذا المخ اض
سياخذ وقت قد يكون ممتد لعده سنوات قادمه
نعم هذا صحيح وهذا المخاض نراه في اعاده
تشكيل ما يسمى بالاقلمه الشركات
الاستراتيجيه بين دول العالم بدات تتحول
من شركات الاستراتيجيه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى شركات الاستراتيجيه مع
اسبانيا ونيوزيلندا والصين واليابان
بحيث وجنوب امريكا بحيث انها تستطيع ان
تحصل على سلاسل الامداد التي بدات تتقطع
بشكل كبير جدا في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في
امريكا وغيرها من الدول برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في الواقع صدر قرار تقريره قبل
يومين ان 70 مليون اخرين من جميع دول
العالم باتوا على شفا المجاعه والفقر منذ
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
هذه الدول ان تقف مكتوفه الايدي نحن نعلم
وانت تعلم اكثر العالمين في هذا الشيء بان
التضخم يعرف بانه ضريبه على الفقراء لانه
يؤثر على ذوي الدخل المنخفض فالعالم
العربي مثلا بخلاف الدول النفطيه سيكون
اكثر المتاثرين بهذا التضخم هو التضخم
المستورد يسميه تضخم المستورد لانهم
يستوردوا جميع منتجات مشترياتهم من خارج
دول العالم العربي لا خدمه افريقيا مثلا
35 بلدا من اصل 55 في القاره الافريقيه
تستورد القمح والحبوب الاخرى من روسيا
واوكرانيا و22 دوله تستورد الاسمده من
البلدين لذا فان التنميه بنك التنميه
الافريقي يعتقد ان اسعار المواد الغذائيه
سوف ترتفع في افريقيا بنسبه 20 الى 50%
وهذه هي هنا الضريبه على الفقراء التي جئت
على ذكرها مئات الملايين منهم حول العالم
لربما هؤلاء هم الضحايا الذي لا صوتهم
كل يوم انت جئت على ذكر
مؤسسه الفاو ومنظمه الفاو للاغذيه مؤشر
الفود برايس اندكس لديهم
يشهد تراجعات دكتور فواز ونحن نشهد ايضا
في الاسواق التي يتم التداول عليها
للاغذيه والحبوب مؤشر الفاو تراجع في
يناير للشهر العاشر على التوالي هل تعتقد
بانه ازمه التضخم في طريقها للحل في رايك
اقل هذا الجانب
قد تكون في طريقها للحل اذا استطاعت الدول
الاخرى
عوضا عن اوكرانيا وروسيا مثل جنوب امريكا
التي تهتم بالزراعه ان تحل محل اوكرانيا
وروسيا في دكتور انا اعتذر منك بشده لهذا
الانقطاع ولكن يجب ان نذهب الان مباشره
نعود الى مجلس الامن وكلمه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ودمرت اكثر من نصف شبكه الطاقه
في هذا البلد وقصفت اكثر من 700 مستشفى
و26 الف مدرسه واختطفت على الاقل 6000 من
الاطفال الاوكرانيين بعضهم لا يتجاوز بضعه
اشهر واعادتهم رحلاتهم باحرار الى روسيا
لكن الروح في اوكرانيا تبقى غير مهزومه بل
انها اكثر قوه وعزما من اي وقت مضى عندما
اطلقت اوكرانيا العمليه المضاده التي سمحت
باعاده وضع اليد على جزء من اراضيها ارسل
الرئيس بوتين 300 الف شخص ورحل مزيد من
الاطفال
وكذلك اطلق مجموعه فاجنر ومرتزقه ارتكبوا
فضائح من افريقيا وشرق الاوسط والان في
اوكرانيا
طبعا ليست هذه القصه الكامله عن هذه السنه
تمت قصه الشعب الاوكراني
عدد القوات الروسيه كان يفوق عدد القوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن الاوكرانيين وقفوا
مدافعين عن حقهم بتقرير مستقبلهم وقفوا في
وحده وتضامن فيما يتعاملون مع هذا العدوان
مدرسون اعطوا دروس في
للاطفال وعملوا على اعاده اتاحه الطاقه
وتضامن الجيران لاطعام الروعه في هذه قصه
كذلك كيف ان الاسره الدوليه وقفت وتضامنت
معظم الدول الاعضاء مرات عديده ادانه
انتهاكات روسيا لميثاق الامم المتحده
ومحاولاتها لوضع اليد والاستيلاء على
اراضي اوكرانيه يوم امس 140 دوله في
الجمعيه العامه صوتت لصالح قرار يعيد
التاكيد على المبادئ الاساسيه المتعلقه
بسياده وسلامه اراضي اوكرانيا ويندد
بالفضاء التي ترتكبها روسيا ويعبر عن
التضامن كذلك
حسب ميثاق الامم المتحده
عندما حاول الرئيس بوتين ان يستخدم الجوع
اداه ويؤدي الى استعار ازمه غذائيه هي
الاخطر ردت الاسره الدوليه سريعا
منذ الاجتماع الذي انعقد في مايو حول هذا
الموضوع قامت 100 دوله بالاعلان مجموعه من
الالتزامات للتخفيف من حده الجوع من خلال
مساعي الامين العام وكذلك تركيا جاءت
مبادره تصير الحبوب من خلال البحر الاسود
الى
ايطالي هذه الحبوب والتخفيف من كلفتها
للعالم والان فيما تحاول موسكو مره جديده
ان تقوض ذلك يجب ان نضمن
توسيع هذه المبادره
وعندما حاول الرئيس بوتين ان يستخدم
الطاقه اداه زدنا من التزويد عبر العالم
وذلك حتى تمكن الناس من ان يحضروا
بالتدفئه في خلال الشتاء وكذلك للحد من
الاتكال على الطاقه الروسيه
عانت اوكرانيا اشد المعاناه طبعا من الحرب
روسيا ولكن كل دوله استشعرت بهذه المعاناه
الا ان الدول عبر العالم ما زالت تقف الى
جانب اوكرانيا لاننا نقر جميعا بانه لو
تخلينا عن اوكرانيا اليوم فنحن نتخلى عن
ميثاق الامم المتحده بحد ذاته وعن القواعد
التي تضمن اماننا جميعا وسلامتنا
ان الاستيلاء على الاراضي بالقوه وان محو
حدود دوله اخرى وان استهداف مدنيين في
الحروب وان حروب العدوان كلها غير مقبول
بها ولو لم ننتصر لهذه المبادئ فهذا يحدو
بنا الى عالم
يسيطر فيه القوي على الضعيف والعالم الذي
انشئت هذه المنظمه لوضع حد لها واعضاء هذا
المجلس عليهم مسؤوليه خاصه الا وهي الا
نعود الى هذا الشكل من العالم ويمكن ان
نقوم بذلك من خلال سوبر ثلاث اولا يجب ان
نضغط باتجاه سلام عادل وشامل طبعا التوقع
ان دولا عديده سوف تطالب بالسلام اليوم
ولكن لا احد يريد السلام اكثر من الشعب
الاوكراني والولايات المتحده اوضحت جاليا
[موسيقى]
ومن مجلس الامن مشاهدينا الى الجانب الاخر
من الاقتصاد العالمي حيث عانق اقتصادات
الدول الناشئه اوضاعا صعبه بعد ان اشعلت
الحرب فتيل التضخم الذي بدا بالارتفاع
نهايه عام 2021 وهو ما ادى الى زياده قويه
باسعار الفائده التي انعكست ايضا سلبا على
تكلفه الاقتراض وتضخم ديون هذه الدول
الاقتصاد المصري احد الاقتصادات الناشئه
الاقتصاد المصري هو احد الاقتصادات
الناشئه هذه الذي تاثر سلبا من اثار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه فكيف كان تاثير هذه
الازمه على مصر نتعرف على الاجابه في هذا
التقرير
تحمل الحرب في اوكرانيا اثارا صعبه على
اقتصادات الدول الناشئه ولعل الاقتصاد
المصريه دليل على ذلك بعد ان محت الحرب 6
سنوات من مكاسب الاقتصاد المصري منذ بدء
تنفيذ برنامج الاصلاح الاقتصادي بالتعاون
مع صندوق النقد الدولي عام 2016
فقد تراجع احتياطي النقد الاجنبي ليسجل
ادنى مستوى له في اغسطس عند 33 مليارا
ومائه واربعين مليون دولار من 41 مليار
دولار في فبراير وتم خفض الجنيه ثلاث مرات
ورفع الفائده 800 نقطه اساس وسجل معدل
التضخم الاساسي نهايه يناير الماضي
31.2% على اساس سنوي كما خرجت استثمارات
للاجانب في ادوات الدين بقيمه 22 مليار
دولار هذه الاثار ولو بحده اقل تكررت بين
عدد من الدول الناشئه وسط التاثيرات
المستمره للحرب على الاقتصاد العالمي
عموما ولكن ربما هذه الاثار قد تفاقمت في
مصر نتيجه علاقتها الاقتصاديه بكل من
روسيا واوكرانيا عندنا تاثر نتيجه لعلاقه
مباشره قللت الدخل من السياحه
تاثر لارتفاع سعر القمح والمواد الغذائيه
اللي بتيجي من روسيا واوكرانيا
وتاثر غير مباشر نتيجه لسحب الاستثمارات
الساخنه اللي تم سحبها من السوق المصري
وده بالتالي دخلنا في دائره مفرده ان مصر
ابتدت لازم يكون لها رد فعل ورد فعلها
انها هتبتدي انها ترفع الفايده وده برضو
اثر على مصر انها زودت التكلفه على
المصنعين والتجار والمزارعين في مصر لما
رفعت الفائده زاد التضخم فالتضخم في مصر
زاد عندنا مشكله تانيه برضو ظهرت في الوقت
ده نتيجه لسحب الاستثمارات الساخنه وهي
نقص الدولار وللخروج من الازمه لجات مصر
الى صندوق النقد الدولي في اتفاقا جديدا
تحصل بموجبه على قرض بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات
دولار
طبعا الاقتصاد المصري بيمر بسنتين اعتقد
سنتين عشرين 23 وعشرين اربعه وعشرين هما
الاشد وطئه على الاقتصاد المصري مثير مثل
كل دول العالم لكن اقصاد المصري يعتقد
انهم سنتين محوريتين له الاقتصاد المصري
بشان كبير اذا تعافت الدوله المصريه
واستطاعت الدوله المصريه الالتزام بسداد
مديونياتها بشكل كبير والتفكير في كيفيه
الحصول على النقد الاجنبي لتوفير العجز
والعجز في ما بين المطلوب من الدوله
المصريه دفع وما بين وايرادات الدوله
المصريه اعتقد ان هو ده العنصر العنصر
الهام دفع الدوله المصريه وقدرتها على
الالتزام بسداد مديونياتها خلال السنتين
القادمين 20 23
اذا مرت هذه الفتره على الدوله المصريه
بخير اعتقد ان التعافي سيكون بدايه من 20
25 وهي مرحله هامه جدا ويجب ان يكون
للدوله المصريه خطه طموحه جدا في رؤيه
عامه لاستراتيجيه وطنيه للاقتصاد فيما بعد
هذه المرحله
معاناه الاقتصاد المصري ليس من المتوقع ان
تنتهي قريبا خاصه مع استمرار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتبعاتها على الاقتصاد
العالمي والتي تتزامن مع سياسه نقديه
تشدديه رفعت اسعار الفائده عالميا
لمستويات قياسيه ما يصعب من قدره الدول
الناشئه على الحصول على التمويل او خدمته
محمد زهير العربيه
كان هذا هذه وقفتنا مشاهدينا مع التغطيه
الاقتصاديه
للذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب الاوكرانيه
طبعا نعود الان مباشره الى رشا الاستكمال
التغطيه الخاصه المستمره على شاشه العربيه